el cartel se lee con claridad buscados
por el fbi son seis agentes de la
inteligencia militar rusa conocida como
gsv a los que la justicia de eeuu les
imputa una serie de ciberataques de alto
perfil
como muestra este caso ningún país ha
utilizado sus capacidades cibernéticas
de manera tan maliciosa e irresponsable
como rusia causando sin motivo daños
colaterales sin precedentes para
perseguir pequeñas ventajas prácticas y
ataques por rencor 23 en sets space
según la investigación los hackers
actuaron por primera vez en 2015 con un
ataque a la red eléctrica en ucrania
pero fue específicamente en 2017 cuando
causaron más daño la campaña
presidencial de manuel macrón fue
objetivo de una operación de pirateo y
filtración a través de estafas de
phishing y la publicación de documentos
auténticos de la campaña en línea de
forma anónima
hemos descubierto la actividad de rusia
habíamos hablado con nuestros homólogos
franceses antes de los anuncios públicos
y los eventos que se atribuyeron
públicamente el fin de semana pasado y
les dimos un vistazo de acuerdo a la
inteligencia estadounidense los mismos
agentes rusos fueron response
el software de rescate no te pedía que
bloqueo decenas de miles de ordenadores
en el mundo causando miles de millones
de dólares en pérdidas un rango de
instituciones críticas también se vio
afectado con hospitales y farmacéuticas
en eeuu grandes puertos y la seguridad
de la antigua planta de energía
contaminada de chernóbil los agentes
también son sospechosos de formar parte
de los ataques en los juegos olímpicos
de invierno de 2018 en pyeongchang corea
del sur haciéndose pasar por hackers
norcoreanos moscú nunca asumió la
responsabilidad por el grupo y denunció
un discurso rusófobo y una guerra
psicológica contra rusia